[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous bonjour et
bon livre donc la lecture
paul morand disent à propos de la
lecture dans son livre dans l'ombre
certains souvenirs de lecture vous à
taza une ville autant qu'à votre famille
nous allons peut-être découvrir des
villes dans cette émission alors
nathalie wolf qui est maître de
conférences à liberté de 50 ares va nous
parler du prix de cyril gely tout à fait
merci bernard
nul ne sait ce que nous réserve le passé
c'est comme ça que commence le livre de
cyril gely qui est un livre paru chez
albin michel au printemps dernier alors
se passer c'est celui d'auto anne et
otto hahn et bien il s'apprête à
recevoir le prix nobel de chimie pour sa
découverte sur la fission nucléaire on
est à stockholm on né en 1946 donc
lendemain de la guerre et il est
accompagné de son épouse il se prépare
pour la cérémonie recevoir le prix dans
sa chambre d'hôtel et c'est là que
surgit une certaine lise meitner alors
qu'ils élisent myttenaere les semailles
tenaires c'est une physicienne qui a
travaillé avec lui pendant de très
longues années et ensemble ils ont tout
partagé l'amitié le le gouda recherche
obsession pour la recherche mais à lise
meitner elle ne vient pas pour le
féliciter
pas du tout ça elle vient parce que il
se trouve que à l'époque donc qu'ils
avaient travaillé ensemble et lise
meitner juive avait dû quitter
l'allemagne nazie en 1938 et cinq mois
après son départ que fait auto et bien
auto il publie seul un article annonçant
sa découverte dont cleese vient lui
demander des comptes
alors moi ce que j'ai trouvé extrêmement
intéressant dans ce livre c'est d'abord
ça un livre qui a inspiré d'une histoire
vraie il n'y a vraiment eu ce travail et
cette amitié entre entre auto et élise
et cyril gely va imaginer donc cette
rencontre ces retrouvailles il va faire
revivre notamment
la question du rôle joué par les
scientifiques dans l'allemagne
hitlérienne également la place des
femmes au 6e place professionnelle des
femmes à cette époque donc c'est un
roman historique c'est la grande
histoire mais ce sont aussi les
histoires individuelles avec la question
d'ambition la question de de l'amitié du
courage la question du pardon
ça m'a fait penser à un livre que j'aime
beaucoup de thomasz beernaert mais prix
littéraire dans lequel or moi j'adore
cet auteur trèfle et ross et il
il a interrogé la vanité des
distinctions honorifiques et ce qui est
vraiment bien fait dans ce livre or
c'est un huis clos c'est qu'il est écrit
vraiment comme pièce de théâtre écriture
très simple oui c'est un auteur de
théâtre l'écriture est très simple et on
a vraiment les la règle des trois unités
unité de lieu tout se passe dans la
chambre d'hôtel unité de temps
une seule journée et unité d'action avec
ce face à face comme ça la tension qui
monte la tension psychologique aux
logiques et 7 ce face-à-face vraiment
deux intelligences qui s'affrontent donc
c'est vraiment théâtrale et j'espère que
cette pièce va être joué qu'elle est né
à boulogne-billancourt
cyril est né à boulogne-billancourt il a
eu le césar de 1000 cases de la
meilleure adaptation pour diplomatie
donc c'est vraiment un très grand merci
à nathalie et claire belloc et
comédienne et chanteuse va nous parler
de la moustache d'emmanuel carrère
voilà la moustache d'emmanuel carrère a
c'est un livre très surprenant
d'ailleurs comment écrire un livre aussi
captivant à partir d'une simple
moustache et bien c'est le pari tenu par
emmanuel carrère marque est architecte
il porte la moustache depuis de
nombreuses années il est marié à agnès
il travaille dans un cabinet
d'architecturé avec des collègues qui
sont aussi ses amis
et puis en attendant sa salle de bain
il lui prend lé envie de faire
disparaître sa moustache il se rase la
moustache est déjà dans sa salle de bain
il se réjouit de l'effet que ça va
produire sur sa femme et sur ses amis et
collègues sort de la salle de bains est
là sa femme ne remarque rien il arrive
au travail ses collègues ne remarque
enfin comme si de rien n'était donc il
ne dit rien travail
et puis d'accueil
ça commence à le travail est ce ce fait
que personne ne remarque la disparition
de sa moustache
donc il rumine et puis en fait il finit
par exploser de colère devant agnes il
lui dit mais tu as même pas remarqué je
me suis coupé la moustache et là elle
lui dit qu'il n'a jamais porter la
moustache
alors donc là le lui qui marque et agnès
qui vivaient dans une vie confortable
bien installé et c'est là la vie de mark
va complètement basculé ça va basculer
dans une espèce de folie et donc marque
devra partir au bout du monde pour
tenter de retrouver la paix de retrouver
une identité
alors pendant tout le livre on est
vraiment troublé parce qu'en fait on ne
sait plus nous mêmes
où est la vérité est ce que il portait
la moustache c'est ce qui ne la portait
pas voilà on est on est dans ce trouble
à ceux du marché les murs
emmanuel carrère et des cultures et prix
renaudot prix femina et le fils d'hélène
carrère d'encausse secrétaire
perpétuelle de l'académie française
merci donc donc oui c'est alors il a
écrit il à il a réalisé aussi un film
donc sur ce roman mais je crois que le
film je n'ai pas vu le film je crois que
le film est un peu édulcoré par rapport
au livre qui finit de façon assez
terrible merci claire mexique l'est
alors suzy maltret donc qui s'occupe du
salon du livre de rambouillet qui aura
lieu le 17 novembre qui est président de
l'association areli va nous parler de
nez je ne crois que c'est un livre assez
romantique à la fois assez romantique
peut-être mais surtout très très dur et
qui nous permet à tout à chacun d'eux à
la fois la prudence quand nous
rencontrons l'imprimé sans le connaître
est la fois plein d'interrogations
puisque c'est aussi notre modernité
actuelle qui n'est pas forcément
toujours ce qu'on pourrait croire et
attendre neige de mai c'est un premier
roman mais un premier roman
menée de main de maître et c'est très
rare très rare pour en avoir lu beaucoup
je peux vous dire c'est très rare et
paul renier ce prélat sera un jour je le
pense parmi les grands imaginez
une première rencontre une rencontre
comme vous en avez connu vous moi voilà
et puis cette rencontre devient de plus
en plus importante et elle se concrétise
par la vie de deux personnes qui vont
vivre ensemble qui vivent à cent vont
apprendre à se connaître
et puis ce qui était inattendu dames la
femme
cette femme qu'il aime elle va être
dépressive mais quand je dis dépressive
jeudi jusqu'à l'hospitalisation jusqu'à
la folie et lui pas abba va apprendre
autour de ce qu'il est appelé de ces
cette blessure de ses blessures kit jour
après jour est ce moi est ce ma faute
voilà mais il va apprendre à l'aimer
autrement il n'y a plus de rapports il
n'y a plus rien qu'une femme qui étaient
choqués et hospitalisés
voilà qui ne le reconnaît même pas dans
sa folie et sa c je ne le connais pas ce
monsieur je l'attend donc au salon je me
demande comment moi qui fut infirmière
toute ma vie moi qui fut si près des
eaux puisque infirmiers à domicile qui
avons vu toutes ces folies aussi bien
chez les adolescents comme chez les gens
plus âgés
comment il a pu vous faire rentrer dans
ce monde là et pourtant il dit l'amour
ne s'est pas échoué et deepak sage
échoué ils disent ne s'est pas échoué il
vit tu te consume
je suis là dans la lumière 8ce lente de
l'été le plaisir et parce melesse arras
est stupide
l'euphorique tu es là je suis là
la fin que magnifique et c'est suffisant
bon si tu
merci donc de zéro de passer la parole à
georges carl hozjan ikea éditeurs et qui
va nous parler de la peau leur je crois
oui alors voilà en chasse un excellent
polar donc je vais pas tout vous
raconter parce que c'est terrible
toujours dans les émissions dans les
journaux coton le mot à la mode ces
spoilers enfin que je déteste mais enfin
quand on vous révèle tout sur le sur ce
qui se passe donc là en chasse de jesse
cannes ça se passe dans le nord c'est le
deuxième deuxième opus des aventures de
trois de trois policiers une jeune
capitaine et puis un lieutenant et un
commandant donc le le trio assez
classique ça se passe dans le nord à
côté de shell ils pourchassent des
véritables barbares qui s'en prennent à
des jeunes femmes et qu'il est qu'il
séquestre qui les violent et qu'il les
relâche dans un état assez assez
terrible donc l'intérêt de ce roman
c'est il ya de l'action iliad une
description social absolument
terrifiante de ce qu'est le nord alors
terrifiant parce que il ya effectivement
tout ce qu'on connaît dans de certaines
parties du nord un taux de chômage c'est
incroyable par moments on peut dire un
certain désert culturel un désert même
commercial t centre-ville un peu déserté
mais en même temps c'est tout l'intérêt
de jesse canevas qui décrit aussi un
accord avec des gens d'une extrême s'est
fait un peu lieu comme un homme
extrêmement chaleureux extrêmement
aidant les uns avec les autres et pas du
tout caricatural donc on n'échappe à la
caricature sur le nord mais on se
passionne parce que c'est de bout en
bout
absolument passionnant c'est très bien
écrit c'est d'un point de vue procédure
d'un point de vue policier c'est
absolument exact n'ya pas d'un
correction n'est pas de bêtises qu'on
voit très souvent dans les romans
policiers ou ou les auteurs ces gars en
racontant n'importe quoi aussi bien sur
le rôle d'un avocat que celui d'un
policier donc là on est dans quelque
chose de parfaitement bien construit
bien écrit et assez copieux et assez
assez rude mais tout à fait tout à fait
intéressant donc s'appelle en chasse
parce qu'effectivement les d4 barbares
chaste les jeunes femmes et les trois
policiers chasse les barbares qui chasse
les jeunes femmes en chasse merci je
sors
pour terminer je voudrais vous parler de
la clandestine de voyage de bougainville
écrit par michel kahn est édité chez
points donc c'est une belle histoire d'
aventure
je crois que c'est l'histoire de john
barry c'est la première fan qui a dû
faire le tour du monde en bateau c'est
en 1766 alors que les femmes étaient
interdites à bord mais donc c'est une
histoire assez incroyable
en même temps il ya une histoire d'amour
parce qu'elle était donc elle était
l'amante du de l'ue médecin le
commerçant philibert commerson qui était
bonne stadistes du roi et qui
accompagnait bougainville dans le voyage
autour du monde pour apporter des plans
alors ils se sont connus tous les deux
en saône et loire elle c'était une fille
de ferme est simple kiki qui connaissait
les plantes par sa mère sa grand mère et
ils sont retrouvés tous les deux ans sur
cent des plaintes et il a vu qu'elle
connaissait plein de choses mais comme
elle était mignonne ils sont devenus
amants il a réussi à la faire embarquer
sur le bateau n'est que c'était interdit
aux femmes
donc elle se vendait les laissant faire
des choses comme ça alors je vous dis
pas si ça a été découverts par
l'équipage mais c'est en plus une
histoire vraie quand la réalité dépasse
la fiction c'est extraordinaire donc
cette aventure de jack barret philibert
commerson les aventures de la boudeuse
allez merci au revoir
[Musique]
m